von einer amok lage spricht der
oberbürgermeister zwei menschen wurden
in der nähe einer synagoge erschossen
ein verdächtiger wurde gefasst aber
offenbar sind noch weitere täter
flüchtig zu diesem zeitpunkt sind noch
viele fragen offen die hintergründe sind
noch unklar wir wollen uns das thema
heute anschauen und wenn ihr fragen dazu
habt könnt ihr sie wie immer gerne hier
unten in die kommentare posten
und wir schalten jetzt live zu annegret
oster in halle
annegret wie ist denn aktuell die
situation vor ort ja immer noch
eigentlich die ganzen tag seitdem das
passiert ist die polizei rufe gegen so
kurz vor zwölf tatsächlich ein bei der
polizei ausnahmezustand immer noch
komplett unübersichtlich sie sehen hier
hinter mir es ist weiträumig abgesperrt
hinter diesen sich schützen die seit
etwa einer dreiviertel stunde stehen ist
die synagoge die polizei will
offensichtlich nicht nur absperren
sondern auch einen rein filmen
verhindern
das zeigt die die lage die polizei sagt
weiterhin nichts hält sich sehr bedeckt
hat weiterhin die anwohner aufgerufen zu
hause zu bleiben möglichst sicher weil
sich in den vier wänden straßen sind
relativ leer sind trotzdem einige bürger
unterwegs die sich das ganze natürlich
noch anschauen wollen was hier los ist
das presseaufgebot ist enorm noch sehr
viel mehr polizeiwagen rettungswagen
stehen noch hier
vor ungefähr einer halben stunde gab es
nochmal einer lager sind sehr viele
polizeiwagen richtung ausfahrt halle
gefahren wohin das wissen wir nicht
also es ist einfach noch sehr wenig
bekannt und wir müssen weiter abwarten
und wir kommen schon die ersten
kommentare in die richtung zum beispiel
von ricoh was da genau passiert und wie
kam es zu dieser schießerei und annegret
wir schauen uns das jetzt mal kurz in
einem beitrag an wasser heute passiert
ist
schüsse auf offener straße mitten im
paulusviertel in halle 1 an mona film
sich ein täter sein weg frei schiesst
mit einer großkalibrigen waffe kurz
darauf ist die polizei am tatort ein
augenzeuge erlebt alles aus nächster
nähe mit
ja du hast du blind geschossen und dann
hat er maschine über einen klingt das
anders verpackt weil das mädchen das
kostbare schreiben dann sage ich leute
hier sind würdig zu steigen voller
kampfausrüstung wilhelm schutzkleidung
also komplett geöffnet zudem die
maschine ja und da doch bewerber so
mannschaft rückt jetzt oder salaten oder
friedhofsmauer
sie haben explosionen gehört genau
offenbar haben der oder die täter
erfolglos versucht in die synagoge zu
gelangen
die ist voll besetzt am höchsten
jüdischen feiertag jom kippur richtig
heftig das habe ich schon mitgekriegt
ich will die rote straße hier muss ich
erst mal in deckung gehen
das war wie will christa zwei menschen
werden getötet die polizei ruft anwohner
auf in den häusern zu bleiben
nach dem angriff trennt sich die täter
offenbar und flüchten einer kapert ein
taxi und wird kurz darauf festgenommen
auch im 15 kilometer entfernten
landsberg sollen schüsse gefallen sein
die polizei hat das nicht bestätigt ein
spezialeinsatzkommando ist dort im
einsatz
die fahndung läuft wie viele täter noch
auf der flucht sind ist unklar
die bundesanwaltschaft hat inzwischen
die ermittlungen übernommen es gebe
anhaltspunkte für einen
rechtsextremistischen hintergrund wie
hier in dresden sind bundesweit die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen an synagogen
erhöht worden
ja und um die täter geht es natürlich
auch hier bei uns in den kommentaren
das hat die frage an dich annegret was
es denn jetzt aktuell über die
mutmaßlichen täter bekannt ja noch so
wenig dass ich noch nicht einmal
bestätigen kann dass es zwei täter sind
die polizei bestätigt einen in jedem
fall
es wurde auch ein zumindest verdächtiger
ein mensch festgenommen ob das der täter
ist und ob das der einzige täter ist das
ist noch völlig unklar
es ist auch nicht bekannt wo dieser
verdächtiger dieser festgenommene die es
ist und es ist auch unklar wie gesagt ob
es weitere täter gibt die polizei
verhält sich da
sehr bedeckt und die lage geht wir sehen
es ja hier hinter uns tatsächlich auch
noch weiter und deswegen ist natürlich
auch die zurückhaltung der polizei
natürlich groß auch deshalb weil so
sagte ein polizeisprecher der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen an
sich gezogen hat und das bedeutet für
die polizei hier in halle dass sie auch
pressemitteilungen zurückhält
heute nachmittag wurde eine
pressemitteilung angekündigt dass sie es
in wenigen minuten gibt es die wird hier
raus gegeben
auf die warten wir immer noch bzw nicht
mehr weil jetzt die aussage ist dass die
hallenser polizei sich komplett aus
allen presseberichten und auch aus der
kommunikation mit der presse
zurückhalten wird weil es eben abgegeben
worden ist hier kommt die frage bei
youtube wie die polizei denn jetzt
vorgeht weil er offenbar noch nach
tätern gesucht wird kannst du dazu etwas
sagen
also es ist hier noch sehr viel polizei
wir hören blaulicht um uns herum sind
viele polizei also wenn ich jetzt hier
gucken hier ist einer da hinten auch
also es ist sehr viel blaulicht zu sehen
das heißt es ist ein ich sag mal einen
einsatz in bewegung
ja aber wo die jetzt hinfahren was die
aktuelle situation ist darüber haben wir
keine auskünfte
was wissen wir denn bisher zu den opfern
es gibt zwei tote ein mann und eine frau
offensichtlich ist es so dass der täter
einen selbst gebastelten sprengsatz in
den jüdischen friedhof neben der
synagoge geworfen hat was dann passiert
wissen wir nicht auf jeden fall wurde
ein mann in einem jahr mittel nahe
gelegenen kiosk dann erschossen
jemand der sich hier gut auskennt sagte
mir naja vielleicht zu 350 meter weg sei
dieser kiosk also nicht wirklich in
unmittelbarer nähe dieser synagoge
der mann war wohl nur zufällig da aber
auch das sind spekulationen
der ist ja der ist erschossen worden
eine weitere frau in der nähe der
synagoge draußen auf der straße ist
ebenfalls opfer der oder des täters
geworden es gibt zwei weitere verletzte
die sind hier im krankenhaus in halle
eingeliefert und auch mit schuss beide
mit schussverletzungen mittlerweile
operiert worden
was jetzt gerade auch schon die synagoge
angesprochen und ist ja heute auch ein
besonderer tag für die jüdische
gemeinschaft ist er mittlerweile klar ob
die synagoge tatsächlich das ziel dieses
angriffs war
also es gibt einen den sprecher hier der
jüdischen gemeinde in halle der wird
zitiert der hat gesagt dass er mit 70
bis 80 jüdischen gemeinde mitgliedern
die eben jom kippur diesen höchsten
jüdischen feiertag in der synagoge
begangen haben
dass die über eine kamera gesehen haben
wie dieser angreifer in die synagoge
eindringen wollte bewaffnet er hat eine
art kampf monitor im monitor montur an
gehabt und wollte reihen hat das aber
offensichtlich nicht geschafft also es
es steht zu befürchten dass es
tatsächlich die synagoge das ziel dieses
anschlages war und jetzt hat ja auch die
bundesanwaltschaft die ermittlungen
übernommen
und wir haben unseren kollegen felix
zimmermann von recht und justiz bei uns
hier im zdf gefragt was das bedeutet die
bundesanwaltschaft hat uns mitgeteilt
dass sie die ermittlungen übernommen hat
weil die täter in krankheiten
zudem maschinenpistole benutzten und das
wohl an unterschiedlichen orten
gleichzeitig wird von der
staatsgefährdenden straftat weise
terrorismus aus
auch die festgenommene person zu den
tätern gehört ist aktuell noch unklar
ja da kommen hier auch noch ein paar
fragen reihen angeht da bin ich mir gar
nicht sicher ob du sie beantworten
kannst vielleicht und zwar kommt hier
eine frage bei youtube haben sie schon
die meldungen vom täter gehört welcher
seine tat wohl auf der streaming
plattform twitter stream tagesaktuell
geht dies auf twitter samt foto und link
um hast du dazwischen irgendetwas gehört
nein man muss aber sagen dass die
polizei auch dazu aufruft bei twitter
sich wirklich spekulationen zu enthalten
sie sagt auch wenn jemand hinweise hat
vielleicht auch videos gefilmt bitte an
die polizei geben und nicht in die
sozialen netzwerke da ist wirklich viele
dinge die teilweise von der polizei
wieder dementiert wurden mittlerweile
will das gar nicht wiederholen also sind
viele sachen den umlauf der mann die man
nicht glauben schenken sollte und
wirklich erstmal abwarten sollte was
dann von der polizei tatsächlich
bestätigten nun in landsberg etwa 15
kilometer entfernt von halle soll es ja
auch schüsse gegeben haben was es
darüber bisher bekannt
ganz wenig weil sich dazu auch die
polizei sehr zurückhält
dort gibt es ein freiheits kamerateam
mit dem ich ein paar stunden telefoniert
habe die filme dort und von denen weiß
ich dass es tatsächlich einen einsatz
gegeben hat dass viel polizei polizei
fahrzeuge auch schweres gerät zu sehen
war wie gesagt die polizei hält sich
zurück hat mir dazu überhaupt gar nichts
gesagt gibt auch keine offiziellen
interviews dazu
deswegen ist das also auch dieses
wirklich im bereich der spekulation
auch ob das in irgendeiner weise eine
verbindung hat mit hiermit halle das was
ganz anderes ist ob es überhaupt china
ist soll schießereien gegeben haben das
hat die polizei ausdrücklich nicht
bestätigt also man sieht das ist alles
noch sehr im schwange und offizielle
meldungen gibt es wirklich noch wenige
gibt es denn zumindest ein hinweis waren
die polizei sich äußern möchten apk oder
ähnlichem bitte das habe ich nicht
verstanden oder ob ist schon eine info
von der polizei gibt wann sie sich denn
auch äußern will zum beispiel an einer
pressekonferenz also waren wir mit neuen
erkenntnissen rechnen können von seiten
der polizei also laut der in diese
polizeisprechers mit dem ich vor etwa
anderthalb stunden gesprochen habe er
sagte mir wir werden überhaupt keine
pressemitteilungen mehr rausgehen wir
werden auch keine interviews geben das
ist alles bei der
generalbundesanwaltschaft und die hat
die ermittlungen an sich gezogen und
gleichzeitig verbunden mit der bitte an
die polizei wohl in halle so sagte er
mir dass die kollegen sich vor ort die
polizei eben zurückhält und daran halten
sich die kollegen wir haben hier eine
zuschauerin oder ein zuschauer bei
youtube da schreibt ich wohne nur eine
straße weiter
und die lage ist ja jetzt noch sehr
unklar also was bedeutet das denn jetzt
für die bevölkerung vor ort
die polizei hat die warnung oder die
bitte doch am besten zu hause zu bleiben
nicht aufgehoben das heißt ich denke das
ist weiterhin das sicherste
ich persönlich fühle mich jetzt hier
nicht unsicher aber fakt ist es ist
nicht sehr wird nicht nicht angenehm und
nicht schön hier zu stehen man sieht
auch nichts weiter als ich kann
eigentlich alle nur davor warnen jetzt
um jetzt muss ja nein
es muss hier um die ecke ich denke
wirklich es ist das sinnvollste zu hause
zu bleiben und abzuwarten
ich glaube eine momentane gefahr aber
das ist meine persönliche meinung gibt
es im moment hier nicht die
polizeiaufgebot ist wirklich massiv und
groß aber ich kann nur sagen abwarten
ich denke im laufe des morgigen tages
wird es in jedem fall mehr erkenntnisse
geben aber auch das ist eine mutmaßung
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen die
bürger sind jetzt zu hause es wird
dunkel es regnet jetzt hier auch und
vielleicht müssen wir morgen früh da im
laufe des abends genauer weiß annegret
oster dann ganz herzlichen dank für
diese einschätzung und die bisherigen
erkenntnisse gerne und dann jetzt noch
eine info von meiner seite die polizei
halt halle hat nämlich ein
hinweistelefon eingerichtet und zwar
unter der nummer 0345 224 17 12 und wenn
ihr nach fragen habt dann könnt ihr euch
auch jederzeit unter der 115 melden oder
bei ganz akuten situationen natürlich
wie immer unter der 110 und hier im zdf
gibt es neue informationen zu der
schießerei in halle direkt im anschluss
an die 19 uhr nachrichten mit einem zdf
spezial vielen dank fürs zuschauen
[Musik]